as a
huge fan of pete's dragon uh i mean and
everyone on collider loves pete's dragon
um we are all so curious about peter pan
and wendy
and your take on the material what
excited you to make it
and maybe you know how is it different
than the other peter pans
that have come before personally
speaking it's my favorite thing i've
ever made
which i wasn't expecting going into it
but it is it's i'm
i've never been as in love with a movie
as i am with this one and we're on day
we just finished day 91 of principle of
shooting we've got a couple weeks left
to go
and i am i just love this movie and it's
the most
personal thing i've ever made it's the
most i don't know i just love everything
about it
but it is ironically the most
adult movie i've ever made and i went
into it thinking that
you know my way in was my my entryway
into this movie was that i've
got a classic case of peter pan syndrome
i don't want to grow up
who does and i thought that was what was
going to appeal about to me about it but
in making it
in writing it and then now directing it
and seeing it come to life i've realized
that this is a movie about me letting go
of that and
i don't know whether that's good or bad
i don't i haven't processed yet but
it's the first movie i've made from an
adult perspective
if that makes any sense and so it's very
true
to both you know the original book and
to the elements of the disney movie that
we can adapt
you know obviously there's a lot of
things about the animated film that
you're just going to let
leave to leave to the darker side of
history but it's it's then we're not
reinventing the tale
but i hope that we are illuminating it
and making it
a movie of great import it'll be you
know it'll be
an entire generation's first peter pan
movie and that's something i don't take
lightly and i want this to be a movie
that
is is important to the the children who
see that you know
peter pan's an evergreen property it's
something that will be remade and retold
ad infinitum for the rest of time this
version of it will be
you know it's my version of it it's the
version that for the next you know 10
years will probably be the one that
kids watch for the first time until it
gets remade again and i want
uh i i want to make a movie that
will matter to that the kids will look
back on fondly and
think that they they got something from
it that they learned something from it
that it mattered to them
and i hope that adults will feel the
same way because me as as someone who
is just now finally feeling comfortable
with calling myself an adult
i think there's a lot of valuable
material that we've we've
pulled from the source from the text and
i'm i don't know i'm really
i've said it already i'm just in love
with this movie and i really am excited
to
to show it to people